hello everybody and welcome to the
second part of reading Unicode either
from websites files or whatever in this
scenario we're gonna kind of be framing
this around Twitter but the next
question that you're gonna have is again
if we if we reference the file here so
let me just pull up one of our examples
here you'll see that actually what's
happened is unicode is just kind of
dispersed inside regular text I'm trying
to find it a line sorry if this is like
doing y'all's eyes pain trying to find
one that has regular text and some
Unicode like thrown into it let me zoom
out oh here we go right here right so
die press CC for Arabic and then it's
got like yes a new line I'm not sure why
that new line is there in a tweet but
anyway then you've got some Unicode here
and also you know Twitter's Unicode also
includes their little Smiley's and all
that stuff so it's not just languages
it's any symbol so anyway here's a line
right that has both Unicode and regular
text and you'll see that as as its
tossing you unicode it's not giving you
that required you remember I was saying
that like if you just print out this as
a string it's not going to give you what
you want so how do we actually get what
we want from this so so what I'm gonna
go ahead and do I think we'll just I
think we'll just delete all of this
right because now now what we're trying
to do is let's say you've you've saved
your output to like say you're reading
from Twitter or another website that's
doing this to you and you've saved your
output it's gonna be saved in that
format that I just showed you it's not
going to have this this lovely you
higher so now how do we handle that like
if you're reading from a database or our
case I'm just going to use a sample CSV
so we're just going to say sample file
equals open and in here my sample file a
small Arabic dot CSV and we're going to
use
read for this and actually now that I
think about it I might well I can't put
these since these are like with actual
tweets I won't be able to put these up I
was thinking I was gonna put like some
these sample files up on my website but
I can't cuz I don't own the rights to
that so I like Twitter is pretty bad
about you can't store tweets for longer
than like 24 hours and all this stuff so
I won't even be able to put these up on
my website but if you if you are
following either my stream tutorial you
can get your own sample file I do show
how you can save it in a CSV or a text
and then also it you can just like you
can view Twitter control you and the
same thing like there paste it out there
in JSON format as well interestingly
enough anyway
so you have to get the sample file on
your own I'd literally I just can't
legally put that up but anyway dot read
so my file is called small Arabic it's
just small Arabic just refers to it's a
small sample of Arabic text and I've got
a larger sample of Arabic text so that's
why it's called small anyway
split file is gonna equal sample file
I'm and then we're gonna do for each
line in split file we'll just print each
line for now so we can see what we're
working with here and just show you that
one it's it's you know Arabic and
Unicode there is no you prior to tell
you hey this is Unicode by the way and
even now the console is not
automatically converting it either
because it's just treating it like a
string so the next thing you need to do
is convert it or note I guess you're not
really converting it necessarily but
you're notifying and you are at least
putting into the X variable what you
want so x equals each line dot and code
so this sounds pretty typical
I would assume for you guys utf-8 but
let me show you here what happens see
normally each line is strictly
string.format but now let's see what
happens when we've encoded it in the
utf-8 format so like ASCII characters
are a part of utf-8 right so like it
goes like a ski and then I forget what
comes after a ski but there's like two
of the more common ones and then you've
got all the crazy symbols following and
so utf-8 encompasses a ski but this is
now Unicode right and so anyway let's
just print it to console so you can see
one
yep yappin about so you can see there's
really no no difference in what we're
seeing so far but now what we can do is
notify it that actually now what we want
to do is decode this encoded utf-8 okay
and we want to do it in Unicode - escape
and this is because we're notifying it
that Unicode is being escaped so you can
look here every Unicode character is not
just a you because like that's the
definition of this Unicode character
right it's the 630 ahthe Unicode but
it's also but to notify us that it is
Unicode it's an escaped Unicode and then
the number so that's how we can notify
our machine how this should be read so X
dot decode Unicode - escape escape it so
now when we do this you'll see that we
got text and Arabic and there's our
message that I was talking about earlier
as you can see that box that even
Twitter couldn't get we got and that's
just a heart so so I pretty much should
cover everything you would need to know
as far as like reading Arabic from
websites any especially like Twitter
obviously your output might be the
entire JSON with Twitter depan like what
you're pulling specifically from Twitter
but if you convert it from just your
typical ASCII to utf-8 which encompass
is ASCII characters you can get
everything that you want and then you
just need to define what is specific
Unicode because all the definition for
Unicode and the numbers and all that
that's done with typical ASCII
characters right so you just have to
tell it how to read it and that's that's
pretty much it so then from that point
you can either compare either convert to
Unicode that's you know all the symbols
are gonna be in Unicode anyways so you
can compare assemble the symbol or you
can even compare something like the
Unicode itself you know the code of the
Unicode compare that to the code for the
for the other symbol depending on how
you want to do that if you're gonna do
any analysis before you're looking to do
is just display this somehow this would
be how you would do it
so hopefully that has helped some of you
guys out again that was pretty highly
requested that uh that people were kind
of confused as far as how to do it and
as far as like looking around online I
couldn't really find too much too many
examples to like link anybody to so
hopefully that's useful for some of you
guys as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support in the
subscriptions and until next time